dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jean affair
we are currently more than 130 episodes
into the series and we still haven't
talked about this algorithm how could we
go on for so long without patch match so
let's do this right now you'll love this
one this technique helps us to make
absolutely crazy modifications to
previously existing photographs and it
is one of the landmark papers for all
kinds of photo manipulation which is
still widely used to this day
consider the following workflow we have
this image as an input let's mark the
roofline for hole filling or image in
painting as the literature refers to it
and the hole is now filled with quite
sensible information now we mark some of
the pillars to reshape the object and
then we pull the roof upward the output
is a completely redesigned version of
the input photograph Wow absolutely
incredible and the whole thing happens
interactively almost in real time but if
we consider the hardware improvement
since this paper was published it is
safe to say that today it runs in real
time even on a mediocre computer and in
this piece of work the image completion
part works by adding additional hints to
the algorithm for instance marking the
expected shape of an object that we wish
to cut out and have it filled with new
data or showing the shape of the
building that we wish to edit also have
the technique considerably these results
are so stunning I remember when I had
first seen them I had to recheck over
and over again because I could hardly
believe my eyes
this technique offers not only these
high quality results but it is
considerably quicker than its
competitors to accomplish image in
painting most algorithms look for
regions in the image that are similar to
the one that is being removed and
borrows some information from there for
the feeling process here one of the key
ideas that speed up the process is that
when good correspondences are found if
we are doing another lookup we shouldn't
restart the patch matching process but
we should try to search nearby because
that's where we are most likely to find
useful information you know what the
best part is what
see here is just a start this technique
does not use any of the modern machine
learning techniques so in the era of
these incredibly powerful deep neural
networks I can only imagine the quality
of solutions we'll be able to obtain in
the near future we are living amazing
times indeed thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time
[Music]